[Müzik]
her konuşmaya çıktığımda aklımda delik
soru var ama soramıyorum çünkü o an
yaptığım işle ilgili bunu sorma o
bağlandı çok gereksiz oluyor ama bugün
anlatacağım şeyle ilgili çok ilgili bir
soru olduğu için size sormak istiyorum
ya bu Sabun da ne kadar içe dönük var ne
kadar dışa dönük var benim Aklımdaki
esasında o deli soru
[Müzik]
Peki bilmiyorsanız senin kaldırmanıza
gerek yok içe dönük dışa dönük
olduğunuzu bilmeyebilirsiniz ne
kadarınız içe dönük ya da içe dönük
olduğunu düşünüyor
yine Aziz Her zamanki gibi
ben Murat yerde kalmaz Eğer ve ben
böyle deyince Hani Arsız bağımlılar
terapi grubu oluyor ya oradaki tanıtım
gibi oldu ama
İddialı oldu bana yani ruhsal bir
bozukluğu varmış gibi davrandık Aslında
var da bunu mu diyeyim bunu da başka bir
konuşmandan anlatırım
gayreti bunu rahatsızlığı var ama içe
dönük olmamla ilgili bana böyle
davranıldığını derseniz etrafındaki dışa
dönükler esasında Beni seven insanlar
ailem işte Okulda öğretmen dedim İş
hayatına başladıktan sonra yöneticinin
yanına Niye sesin çıkmıyor niye
toplantıda konuşmuyorsunuz oğlum
biliyorsun niye okulda parmak
kaldırıyorsun ya ben bu sırada bugün
gereksiz olduğunu düşünüyordum ve benim
için çok normaldi aslında
kısa dönükler kalabalık bir grup olduğu
için ve
onlar ırklarını bir sosyal norm olarak
kabul ediyorlardı yani normali mi diye
görüyorlardı kötü niyet
li
esasına bakarsanız
Tabi ben bunu barışmam biraz zaman aldı
işte 30'larımın başındaydım bir şirkette
çalışıyordum bir kurumsal şirkette bir
eğitime gittim orada bir kişilik
envanteri yapıldı bana belki aranızda
yapılan kişiler vardır ve orada ben
aslında Geçende ilk kez öğrendim daha
çok da birbirinden farklı bir şey olmadı
daha doğrusu özellikle birbirinden
farklı türünden daha iyi olmadan
ikisinin de normal bir kişilik
durumu Çok klişe bir gri Kariyerim oldu
sonrasında işte 40 yaşlarında yaklaşınca
hayatta böyle bir duvara vurdu ve dedim
ki ben artık beyaz ve kalın olmak
istemiyordum sonrasında işte şirketlere
eğitimler vermeye başladım Koçluk
yapmaya başladım danışmanlık yapmaya
başladım o başlarken de birçok eğitim
aldım tabi psikoloji ile ilgili ciddi
eğitimler aldı ve bu kişilik profilleri
üstünde bayağı
dilimli birine şansım oldu
orada durumla daha çok barışıktım aslına
bakarsanız yani Çin dönük olmamla daha
çok
günden beri aslında
Biz sahneye çok çıkan insanlar değiliz o
yüzden aralarında Bunu beni seçtiler
gibi düşünüyorum
hem de yaratmaya çalışıyorum şimdi bu
konu Tabii benim hikay
emde
İsviçre'nin bir bilim adamı İsviçreli
bilim adamları çok meşhur olup diş
fırçası ve diş macunu reklamları
çıkmadan çok ince bu konulara kafa
yormuş
yılbaşı yanlış hatırlamıyorsam insanları
davranışlarına göre nasıl
gruplayabilirim diye kabul olmuş ve
biraz daha tek başına çalışmayı seven
kişiler olduğunu görmüş ve onlara
bir grubunda daha fazla insanlar
interaksiyonuna girmeyi sevdiğimden
abone olmayı sevginin bu çalışması
yapmayı sevdiğini görmüş onlara da dışa
[Müzik]
dönük biz size bir skala düşünün turuncu
tarafta muamel için Çetin
sola doğru gittikçe içe dönüklük artıyor
gibi
düşünüyorum Ferah
dışa dönüklerimizi anlamamız için
ortadan bir çizgi çizelim ve sizin içe
dönük dışa dönüklerinizi belirliyor bu
yeşil riski gördüğünüz gibi burada içe
dönük tarafı
ağırlıklı basar ama dışa dönük tarafında
olan birisi lisans bu Birisi benim şu
gördüğünüz mavi taraftaki dışa dönük
tarafında Böyle
dışarıda göreceğiz dışa değilim Hatta
bunu şaşırıyorlar yani sen nasıl içe
dönüyorsun falan diye söylüyorlar Mesela
bir dışarıya dönüp dostlarınızda
grafiğiniz yaklaşık böyle bir şey
çıkacaktır Aslında bakarsanız şimdi
böyle anlattığımda sanki içe doğru gider
eşit sayı dermiş gibi anlaşılıyor ama
öyle değil arkadaşlar dünyada Bununla
ilgili yapılan araştırma var mı diye Çok
araştırdım fakat
bulabildiğim en iyi rakam
olarak ben Bizimki gibi Akdeniz
kültüründe bunu çok daha düşük olduğunu
tahmin ediyorum Elimde bir rakam var ama
çok bilimsel olmadığı için paylaşmak
istemiyorum ama
yüzde bu konuyu Tabi bir daha sonra
gelen bilim adamları da Araştırmaya
devam etmişler ve 60'ların ortasında bu
engeb cihazları var ya hani kafaya
takılıyor ve benimdeki dalgalarla
ölçülüyor diye işte Alman bilim adamı
kafayı yoruyor ve içinde Türklerin
neyini dalgalarını anlamaya çalışmıyor
farklılıkları ne diye ve bir ölçüm
yapıyor tahmin edin hangisinin yani
beyin dalgası daha fazla daha yoğun
içerikler diyen
dışı dönüklerdi Ya zaten
doğal olarak
tersini bekliyordum
açıkçası'nın daha az ve daha
yakın olduğunu anlamına gelmiyor bütün
sınırlı anlaşılmasın
aslında yani bayağı içerikli bir olay
oluyor sırada şimdi bunun da bir vasıta
davranışlar çıktıları var bu da nedir
derseniz mesela için Türkler
yani Biz yalnız kalmayı seviyoruz Mesela
bugün ben de konuşma yaptıktan sonra
Umut demeye Ne bileyim
süper falan diye geldiyseniz esasında O
sizin bir dışa dönük olduğunuzu ve
Aslında dışarıdan bir uyarı istediğinizi
söylüyor
kolunuzdan birisi zor buraya getirdiyse
yani arkada oturalım İnternette de var
ilerde değilseniz bu dönemde için
durmuşsun
içe dönükler
önce sonra konuşurlar
önce konuşur sonra düşünürler şimdi
bir toplan
tıda toplantısındayız beraber
bir kim cevap veriyor Tabii ki dışa
dönükler devam ediyor akıllarını
ilk yapıyorlar
işte tecrübesine bakıyorum bilgi
dağarcığına bakıyor acaba bu sorunun
nasıl çözebiliriz diye Ama tabi bu
sırada hatalar üst üste geçiyor Ve bu
toplantısı
çok akıllı değil herhalde ama bir şey
söyleyeyim verdiğim eğitimlerde
özellikle liderlik eğitimlerinin bunu
özellikle söylüyorum İyi bir yönetici
ekibinde bir bütçe dönük varsa en
sonunda ona da sormalı sen ne diyorsun
bu konuyla ilgili
diyet diyoruz temas bulmayı çok
sevmiyorum birazcık da düşük puanla
konuşmayı kurmayı seviyorlar ve Biraz
yüksek sesle konuşuyorlar şimdi böyle
olunca mesela ilk tanışma sırasında
gidiyoruz teması bulunmadığınız için ya
da biraz düşük de ondan konuştuğumuz
için özellikle dışa dönükler tarafından
[Müzik]
yani sinsi Mine ya ondan sonra
diyor ki ben bir şey olmaz Hani bunu iş
hayatında çok başarılı olması mümkün
değil Özellikle de özgüvenimizle ilgili
çok şeyler söyleniyor diyorlar ki bunu
biraz özgü arkadaşlarınızla konusu
bambaşka
hepimizin kendine çok güvendiği konular
vardır hiç güvenemedik konular vardır
Bunun içi dönüklük demek dışa dönüp hiç
alakası yok ama bir işe dönük olduğu
için biraz önce söyl
edikleri
kurdun işi bıraktıktan sonra dünya
sorunlarına kafa yormaya başladı
pandemi zamanında biliyorsunuz
dünyayı yöneten 5 aylık tarafında
hepimize çift takılması için
illuminatinin başına genellikle
kendisinin
çıkar Özellikle de Isaac newtona bir içe
dönük
bütün programları yerle bir etti bir içe
doyukluğu Kemal Sunal hepinizi güldürdü
esasında bunu bir içe döndü Cenk alling
500 milyon adet Harry Potter kitabı
sattı şimdi kim bana söyleyebilir bu
insanların özgüvensiz olduğunu mutsuz
olduğunu
hepimizin mutlu olduğu adamın olmadığı
anlamına
onun için örneklerim var
güneşin batmadığı koca imparatorluk
İngiltere
kraliçe yakın zamanda kaybettik belki
içe dönük olduğu için bu kadar uzun
yaşadı
Kendisi ne en büyük hezimete uğrayan
kişi bütün İmparatorluğu yönettiği dönem
boyunca
Siyasetini için gerekli üstüne konmuştu
bugün bu arada bizim
iş dünyasında durum ne bize en büyük
kazığı isteyeceğim
sen biraz kenara çekildi ama biz buradan
şöyle içe dönüp olabiliriz ama daha da
gitsin
her yerde söyleyip kendimi olduğunu
filmini
orada sevgilisi ya da kız arkadaşı onu
reddediyor ve Bizimki kasıyor diyor ki
milyar sonra o yolculuk boyunca bir sürü
dışa dönüydü ekarp etmeyi biliyor
intikamımızı aldığı için kendisine
Teşekkür ederim ama buradan şunu bir
anlamanızı isterim
şimdi güç deyince
son bölümde biraz güçten bahsetmek
istiyorum aslında için direkt dışarıya
anlatıyor ama daha önceki sunumlarda da
dinledim hep böyle güç konusu aklıma
geldi Konuyu anlattığımda da hep aklıma
geliyor
Şimdi bazen dönem dönem ben bazı
kavramlara kafayı takıyorum güç de
onlardan birisine yıllarca dışa dönükler
tarafından baskılandığı ve üstüne bir
güç uygulandı ya Ne demek bu güç ona
kafa yok
iş arkadaşlar
birine
çiğ yaptırabilme yetkisi şimdi böyle
baktığınızda
mak Kız arkadaşımla beraber o kendisini
İsviçre'de yaşıyor Ben buradayım çok sık
gidip geliyorum mesela dünyanın en
nedeni Ülkesi orada baktım Biraz güç
nasıl kullanılıyor bizim ülkemizde
baktım Biraz önce nasıl kullanılıyor
diye çok ilginç bir şey yaşadı işte
bütün Avrupa ülkesinde olduğu gibi
arabalar duruyor vesile yol veriyor şeye
geldiğinizde yaya geçidi diye Şimdi ben
merak ettim hani İsviçre'de bu ileri
seviyede yani sizin daha böyle yaya
geçidine yaklaşmadan vuruyorlar dedim ki
niye duruyorlar yani
[Müzik]
çok büyük ceza var Sonra dedim ki bunu
sadece cezaevinden mi yapıyorlar Yani
ceza mıdır esasında bunun arkasındaki
kalmaya başladım hayat
ın Araba kullanırken esasında daha çok
yayalara bakmaya başlamıştım İstanbul'da
bulunan hiç bakmıyorum benden daha büyük
arabalara bakıyor Bunu daha güçlü
jeeplere bakıyordu beni ezmesinler diye
ben motor kullan
ıyorum ama
oradaki medeniyetle
vücudundanıma arasında ciddi bir ilişki
var medeniyet bildiğiniz şey yani doğu
batı medeniyetinin gelişmiş ve deneyi
ayağına en önemli bay bastığı esasında
atar demokrasi
demokrasi tahmin edebileceğiniz üzere
Yunanca kelime
[Müzik]
halkın gücü Eğer siz halkın gücünü
çoğunluğun gücü bir anlarsanız
kim Başka model olacak yüzde 50+1 ne
olacak falan artistosuna gidersiniz ve
hiçbir zaman demokratik ve esasında
[Müzik]
Eğer halkın gücü herkese alan açılan
herkesin rahatça yaşayabileceği herkesin
kendisini ifade edebileceği asıllıkları
güçsüzlerin dezavantajlarını da
kendilerini rahatça
ifade edebileceği İsviçre'de Yolda
geçerken bir arabanın beni en
[Müzik]
gücü elinde tutmaya nitelikli olan
Aslında onun peşinden koşmayan
arkadaşlar bugün güçlüyken Eğer
kedilerini alan açmıyorsanız yarın size
adım açılması gerektiğinde
bunu izleyemezsiniz
son olarak 3 gruba mesajım var bir
buradaki insanlar bizi işte internetten
izleyenler ve sonra da izleyecek olanlar
Lütfen şunun bir düşünün hayatınızdaki
güçlü olduğunuz rolleri düşünün yani bir
anne baba olabilirsiniz tanıdığınızda
öğretmen olabilirsiniz öğrencilerinizden
düşünmüşsünüz bir insan olarak doğadan
güçlü zaman
lattı
araba kullanıyor olabilirsiniz
yayalardan düşmüşsünüzdür
[Müzik]
Lütfen şunu bir düşünün gücünüzü
kullanın başka birilerine nasıl
anlatabilirsiniz
[Müzik]
ipleri
luker bırakmayı unutmayın
3 mesajım yoğunlaşın olan içe dönükleri
çok sevdiğim bir poster Türkçesini
bulamadım ne yazık ki diyor ki içe
dönükleriniz Kendi başınıza evlerinizde
gördüklerim
evrenin en
[Müzik]
Bilge ve içe dönük olan mentörlü
yoga’nın söylediği gibi bu sizinle olsun
ama lütfen bir cezai gibi bunu iyilik
için kullanın ve güçsüzlere alanı için
[Alkış]